iran hat also zurückgeschlagen es war
die angekündigte vergeltung für die
tötung ihres gemahls solle man durch die
usa und nun schlag gegenschlag im mai
dreht sich die gewalt im nahen osten
weiter droht ein flächenbrand ein krieg
oder ist die eskalation mit der neuen
botschafters washington erstmal gestoppt
bevor wir das mit dem
bundesaußenminister besprechen auch im
flora über angriffsziele drucken und
stützpunkte in der region
irans raketen der stolz der ayatollahs
sie sollen größe macht und stärke
demonstrieren wie bei den
feierlichkeiten zum vierzigsten
jahrestag der islamischen revolution vor
gut einem jahr kurz zuvor präsentierte
iran seine neueste waffe die
mittelstreckenrakete disco abschreckend
gefährlich medien iran es gibt
sicherlich verbindungen zu russland es
gibt verbindungen zu nordkorea es gibt
aber auch wirklich in ihrer in iran
selbst mittlerweile das know-how aber
mit sicherheit da bis da auch
ausländische unterstützung durch die
raketen die jetzt abgefeuert wurden die
sind durchaus hausgemacht etwa 100.000
raketen sollen dem iranischen arsenal
stehen sie treffen ziele bis 1800
vielleicht 2000 kilometer die rahmens
erz-rivalen israel und saudi arabien
liegen damit in reichweite und natürlich
der irak seit jahren ein schlachtfeld
auf dem amerikaner franzosen briten die
bundeswehr australier kanadier im kampf
gegen denise unterwegs sind
die bundeswehr nutzt außerdem den
luftwaffenstützpunkt als rack in
jordanien auch dorthin würden ist
iranische raketen schaffen
dort kamen gestern die ersten soldaten
an die aus dem irak zurückgezogen wurden
im irak sind aktuell noch knapp über 100
deutsche stationiert in bagdad wie und
vor allem in erbil im nordirakischen
kurdengebiet eine ausbildungsmission für
kurdische kämpfer in einer gegend die
bis vor kurzem noch als relativ sicher
galt bis heute nacht iranische raketen
nach erbil flogen auch wenn offenbar
niemand zu schaden kam von sicherheit
kann für die deutschen in der region
derzeit keine rede sein und in berlin
zugeschaltet dass der
bundesaußenminister heiko maas guten
abend herr maas wie schätzen sie denn
die folgen dieses
raketen angriffs 1 dreht sich die
spirale der gewalt jetzt unaufhaltsam
weiter
also erstmal ist das zu verurteilen was
der iran da getan hat wir haben den iran
aufgefordert nicht nur wir viele länder
auf der welt die ganze europäische union
alles zu unterlassen was jetzt zur
weiteren eskalation beitragen kann und
ich hoffe dass es dabei bleibt dass es
keine opfer gegeben hat und nach all dem
was wir aus washington hören haben wir
die hoffnung und versuchen alle darauf
hinzuwirken dass es jetzt dabei bleibt
und dass jetzt die türen für gespräche
wieder geöffnet werden ja sie sagen
strump hat sich heute erstmal
zurückhaltend geäußert welche signale
bekommen sie dennoch aus den usa wäre
das was wir hören was jumpy jetzt ganz
aktuell gesagt hat ist dass er bereit
ist auch mit deutschland frankreich und
großbritannien mit dem iran zu sprechen
auch im zusammenhang mit dem atom
abkommen das nicht nur darüber
gesprochen werden soll das der iran auch
in zukunft keine atomwaffen haben soll
sondern dass auch die regionale rolle
des irans etwa in syrien im irak im
jemen thematisiert werden muss das
ballistisches raketenprogramm die
haltung gegenüber israel
das halten wir alles für richtig und
wenn das ein signal ist dass jetzt keine
bomben mehr verschickt werden sondern
dass die zeit für diplomatie wieder
gekommen ist
dann wäre das ein außerordentlich gutes
signal
er hat ja auch unterstützung der nato
partner eingefordert wird sie bekommen
also die nato ist ja im irak zb aktiv
und macht dort auch erfüllt wichtige
aufgaben
was wir mit dem irak und dazu sind wir
mit den verantwortlichen in bagdad im
gespräch jetzt klären müssen was ist mit
dem parlamentsbeschluss das parlament in
bagdad hat beschlossen dass alle
ausländischen streitkräfte das land
verlassen sollen
wir glauben aber dass die anti es
koalition nach wie vor hilfreich ist im
iran wir glauben dass das land sehr
instabil wird wenn
knall auf fall die ausländischen
streitkräfte land jetzt verlassen müssen
deshalb sprechen wir darüber was das
bedeutet wir wissen nicht wie die
regierung sich verhält in bagdad aber
letztlich werden wir jede entscheidung
die es dort gibt akzeptieren wir glauben
aber dass die hilfe die wir dem irak
anbieten weiterhin gebraucht wird
allerdings muss ja auch gewünscht sein
herzlichen dank heiko maas das gespräch
haben wir aus termingründen vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
der angriff gestern abend nur ein
weiterer tiefpunkt dieser geschichte
eine innige feindschaft zwischen iran
und den usa
die begann aus iranischer sicht
washington 953 die demokratisch gewählte
regierung stürzte für die amerikaner
wiederum ist den geiselnahmen in ihrer
botschaft in teheran 1979 eine
historische demütigung und dann nine
eleven die anschläge ging zwar nicht von
teheran aus haben amerikas umgang mit
der region aber verändert peter jäger
der elfte september 2001 verändert
amerika und die us-politik präsident
bush versteht die anschläge als
kriegserklärung amerika ruf den kampf
gegen den terror aus auch der iran gerät
ins blickfeld einer neuen aggressiven us
sicherheitspolitik
die größte gefahr für amerika und die
welt sind gesetzlose regime die nukleare
chemische oder biologische waffen haben
oder sie beschaffen
gegenseitiges misstrauen prägte das
verhältnis der beiden länder
schon vor den attentaten jetzt gehört
der golfstaat zu amerikas achse des
bösen 2003 stellt sich raus iran
unterhält ein geheimes atomprogramm die
welt die vereinigten staaten sind
alarmiert in den folgejahren spitzt sich
der konflikt weiter zu us präsident
obama droht sogar mit einem
militärschlag
doch es kommt anders 2015 ein abkommen
keine atomaren waffen im iran
im gegenzug werden wirtschaftssanktionen
abgebaut
heute nach zwei jahren verhandlungen
haben wir mit unseren internationalen
partnern geschafft was jahrzehnte an
feindseligkeit nicht geschafft
der dauerkonflikt zwischen den beiden
ländern beruhigt sich bis er ins weiße
haus einzieht wiederholt spricht donald
trump über das abkommen als
schlechtesten deal aller zeiten im mai
2018 steigt er aus der iran will hat
fehler wenn wir nichts machen wissen wir
genau was passiert dann verhängt schwere
wirtschaftssanktionen die rhetorik auf
beiden seiten wie der chef im juni 2009
10 dann die explosion auf zwei tanker im
golf von oman
die usa machen den iran verantwortlich
im gleichen monat schießt der iran eine
us aufklärungsdrohne abschaum bezeichnet
die aktion als schweren fehler
ordnet einen militärschlag an zieht aber
im letzten moment zurück
eine attacke auf die größte ölraffinerie
in saudi arabien folgt im september 2009
10 wieder beschuldigen die usa den iran
wieder verzichtet der us-präsident auf
einen militärschlag verkündet aber die
verschärfung von sanktionen monate in
denen sich die aggression spirale immer
weiter hochgeschraubt hat doch in denen
donald trump immer wieder beteuerte
verhandeln wolle er in den krieg ziehen
aber nicht ja und zugeschneit ist nun
der nahostexperte udo steinbach guten
abend herr steinbach wie groß ist denn
die gefahr eines krieges im nahen osten
nach den angriffen gestern 8 also ich
glaube sie ist vorerst gebannt es wird
vermutlich keine eskalation ergeben aber
natürlich ist jetzt die frage wie
beginnt man die gespräche wer redet als
erster der amerikanische präsident hat
ein leises angebot gemacht aus teheran
haben wir bisher nichts gehört und wenn
wir die geschichte dieser konfrontation
revue passieren lassen in den letzten
monaten müssen wir wirklich sagen
eigentlich hat sich teheran dem gespräch
den verhandlungen mehr verweigert stärke
verweigert als washington
ja was glauben sie denn welche strategie
verfolgt er an da eigentlich im
verhältnis zu den usa
das ist schwer zu sagen man möchte
natürlich irgendwann wieder ins gespräch
kommen zumindest möchte man den krieg
nicht
und ich denke es wäre gut sich daran zu
erinnern wie der golfkrieg von 1980 bis
1988 beendet wurde zwischen iran und dem
irak
der in dem ja die vereinigten staaten
den irak unterstützt haben damals haben
die 1988 die amerikaner eine iranische
maschine verkehrs verschiedene
abgeschossen
die auf dem weg nach dubai war 250 tote
und das hat in teheran eine diskussion
ausgesetzt zwischen pragmatikern und dem
ayatollah khomeini dabei die pragmatiker
unter ihnen der haben
parlamentspräsident spätere
staatspräsident ja nie haben gesagt wir
müssen den krieg aufhören
waffenstillstand sonst geht die
islamische republik als ganze den bach
runter und horny hat das verstanden er
begann den waffenstillstand zuzustimmen
wie er sagte das sei bitter für ihn
gewesen als den gibt's löcher zu trinken
und ich glaube in einer ähnlichen
situation ist teheran jetzt wieder daran
müsste man den nachfolger von romani
harmony erinnern jetzt zusammenfassend
gesagt es gab schlag gegen schlag beide
parteien haben ihre muskeln spielen
lassen
jetzt spricht trump oder stellt
zumindestens neue verhandlungen in
aussicht
wie realistisch ist es nun wirklich dass
man ins gespräch kommt ich glaube es
gibt keine alternative dazu beide seiten
sehen dass in washington hat man das
längst erkannt auch da will man den
krieg nicht
und noch einmal es hat ja diskussionen
in teheran gegeben ob man ein
gesprächsangebot annehmen sollte der
staatspräsident hu horny der oberste
geistliche führer romy waren da
unterschiedlicher ansicht am ende hat
sich ramelow durchgesetzt
also wird sicher kommen weiter behalten
weiter behaupten oder wird man ihn dazu
bringen ebenfalls ein signal zu setzen
das ist die frage der ball liegt heute
im hof von iran
herzlichen dank oder stein machen das
war unser zdf spezial zu den
raketenangriffen auf us stützpunkte im
irak wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen um
22.25 im auslandsjournal wieder mit
weiteren hintergründen aktuelle infos
zuvor natürlich auch im heute journal
oder jederzeit unter heute.de hier geht
es jetzt weiter mit hält einen
hoffentlich ruhigen abend noch auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]